[Music]
this
is star talk neil degrasse tyson here
personal astrophysicist today
we're going to talk about
protecting earth
from space
chuck always good to have you man always
a pleasure to be here man
yeah i honestly i think today's show
should be called destroying earth
from spain from space or
from within
or for oh or from within
because we seem to be doing our
damnedest to get it done don't we
i i i try to turn a blind eye to that
but i shouldn't what we have to help us
put some of that content on the table is
writer producer director
adam mckay adam welcome to star talk
dude
hello thank you adam adam gets an
applause now you know we i we don't
applaud our guests here but after you
have never applauded you you know i have
never applauded a guest neil but that is
true i'm just so impressed with with
what he has just accomplished so well
let me give put some of his resume out
there so you're a former head writer for
snl all right
and your co-founder of upright citizens
brigade very cool i love their work and
you're also a co-writer along with will
ferrell with uh anchorman
all right that was cool
talladagnon knights
stepbrothers okay uh a co-founder of
funny or die
all right that's a production company if
i remember correctly is that right i
think so that's right and wrote and
directed the big short i distinctly
remember that movie um it was like oh my
gosh this has happened and we lived
through it but that's not why you we
have you on the show right now that's
right that's not why franklin all of
that is gold-plated dross
in comparison to why we have adam on the
show
which is because of my workout routine
which i'm going to share with you today
exactly my diet my weight program
all right that's exactly not the reason
so adam
50 year olds there you go adam has a new
peloton class he wants to
he's trying to plug
the [ __ ] up
[Laughter]
so adam you you wrote directed and
produced the netflix hit
don't look up
it's a movie that is correct okay yes it
is star-studded starting leonardo
dicaprio and jennifer lawrence and uh
you know it's got there's a dozen
famous people who have each starred in
their own films you managed to
collab them together for this script
and
it's about an asteroid a comet that's
headed discovered to be headed towards
earth putting all of life on earth at
risk
and the travails and challenges and
troubles of the scientists trying to
alert the public and everyone ignores
them or discounts it and so
what the hell were you thinking to me
i love it what
what who told you to make this why
who
why did your mama do
explain yourself please you know like a
lot of ideas it came from stark terror
uh which is the last
5 10 20 years 30 years 40 years 50 years
back to
1965 um
of just our culture and our leaders and
our industry and our media ignoring
that we're flooding the you know
atmosphere the climate with co2 and we
are on a bad bad path
and uh you know i had the
fortunate unfortunate uh
experience of colliding with a lot of
this information from reading scientific
reports
and reading a great book by david
wallace wells called uninhabitable earth
which if you haven't read it read it and
it will wake you up when it comes to the
climate
and i really started like my wife can
tell you at a certain point i was losing
sleep and i kept kind of looking at our
world and going what am i missing here
and rather than do you know my initial
idea was oh do a big dramatic
dystopic
serious movie
but then a a friend of mine who's a
journalist made an off-handed joke david
sirota where he just said it's like it's
armageddon
but the asteroid is coming and no one
cares
and i was like that's it and and then i
thought if we could laugh
you know if we could have some laughter
about the crazy world we live in as well
as some big emotions
that maybe that's something that could
go out into the world
and hit millions of people and maybe
jars some feelings lose so
that was it it was down you were born
you were born to make this movie that's
what you're telling me i am telling you
that that i was
plucked from the schuylkill river
outside philadelphia
where i'm from
and they said this child shall make a
movie for netflix like like like dirty
moses pulled
[Laughter]
from the river
i was child shall save us we're going to
clean him up first
well he says school kill that's why i
called him dirty moses because you know
is dirty yeah i'm from philly too so i
can say that i'm also from philly so i
can say that where are you from now in
philly uh i grew up in um well i was in
west philadelphia i was born and raised
uh that's philly yeah but boys the speed
boys the basketball team yeah but i i
actually when i was six-year-old uh six
years old my parents looked at me and
they said oh we got to move because this
boy he could never make it here so then
we
so then we moved to very waspy chestnut
hill where i fit in just perfectly
that's not that explains everything
chuck there it is right there yeah yeah
okay
so so adam what it what what enabled you
to mask this level of talent i'm
presuming i mean these are people who
are well paid in their own movies
so
is there some kind of social cause that
that they get to justify doing this
without having to get their normal
paycheck
no no i mean
you know the cool thing is uh i gotta
give a lot of credit to netflix you know
netflix read this crazy script
and was just like yup we'll roll with
this and
you know the whole kind of emotional uh
impetus for the project
was the idea that there's hundreds of
millions of us out there that are
freaking out even though if you flip
through the tv channels
or you look on you know parts of social
media people seem
like they're freaking out about other
things or they're
you know they don't care or it's about
the stock market or it's about you know
politicians legacies
and the idea was there's a lot of us out
there that can feel what's going on
and that played out with the actors all
the actors we went to were like yup i
want to laugh about this
yeah but but adam
you started describing your concerns
based on climate change but you didn't
make a movie about climate change
maybe it's allegorical but you had to
come into my place into my universe and
tell a tell a tell a climate change
story where you don't even mention
climate change that's because why are
you coming in my space because because
your space and your people have been
trying to kill us since the inception of
your of your uh your whole science it's
always about us the
universe is trying to kill us
that's true
so at what point did you say maybe if i
told it about climate no one would pay
attention so let me tell it about
asteroids so this is a storyteller's
ruse right
yeah yeah in a way because i think one
of the tricky things with the climate
crisis which you gentlemen i'm sure know
is that it's slow and creeping even
though now it's getting much faster and
much more overt
um but i think one of the tricky things
is you know the way we're wired as
humans we know how to freak out and run
from a bear or we know how to like deal
with a
serial killer like we all get that but
the idea that these gases you know this
carbon that we're burning is creating
that you can't see yeah that you can't
see and you have to go to climate
scientists who god bless them
aren't really you know built to like be
the pr front for this story i think it
just falls in a tricky area and so i
thought by replacing
climate uh the climate crisis with uh a
comet which is something we all sort of
mostly get like that's scary
uh would put the spotlight on our
messed up human reaction and and that's
really what the movie's about i mean the
movie's really about how we've you know
buffalled twisted and mutated the very
ways
that we talk to each other through
social media through media
through career through money and and
that's really ultimately what the movie
is about
chuck did you hear how how how politely
he referenced the media ineptitude of
scientists right and what phrase did you
use not just that but the way he uh uh
basically uh cajoled the uh the public
in their response because this movie
could have just as easily been called
hey dumbass
that could have been the name of the
movie
[Music]
i mean the people at large have been you
know chest deep
in bs spin and marketing for decades and
and i think it's tricky i mean you look
at like the resistance to the vaccine
well like you know for decades people
have been getting sold you know crazy
drugs like oxycontin their doctors are
telling them oh yeah take this and then
we're surprised when like a vaccine
comes out and people are like i don't
know about that so there's been a lot of
like marketing pr twisting turning
about science which is crazy and it kind
of makes people have to like figure out
how science works and what real science
is versus marketing pr science so we're
in a tricky spot and and uh so
no you know it was cool to see people's
reactions for for the movie because you
know it went worldwide and everyone was
kind of like oh yeah i get that so let
me ask and i gotta i gotta i gotta i
gotta read my tweet i gotta read my
tweet okay i i don't know if you saw my
tweet adam but i'm gonna read it right
now i did i think i repeated it i love
some uh i love some some love from neil
i i took it
to twitter love
i said finally saw the netflix film
don't look up
a fictional tale of a nation distracted
by pop culture and divided on whether to
heed dire warnings of scientists
everything i know about news cycles talk
shows social media and politics tells me
the film was instead a documentary oh
that's great
that's fantastic that's all just i stood
there flat-footed and and put it out
there
you know
before you go any further since you said
that neil since you just said that was
the fact that it's a documentary what
was the pushback if any adam uh from
what community or any community that saw
this and said
what the hell are you doing or that's a
bunch of bs or oh look at you you
whatever was there any of that
oh yeah yeah we got some of that i mean
any time you do a comedy you know
certain people are going to be with it
or not with it yeah and so that's a
given but then yeah there was some
he means chuck anytime you offend people
people are going to be
that's what he means
anytime you do a comedy right well it
ain't comedy unless somebody's offended
i mean
of the media were not too happy with the
movie i mean we go pretty hard
at the collective media there was one
paper
that's pretty famous for climate denial
where you know their critic did not care
for the movie so you got some of that um
but for the most part uh you know once
the movie premiered on netflix no it was
it was a great
universal response of we know what
that's saying it was it was really
heartening actually because
i think there's this idea that people
don't get it that people are bored they
want entertainment and it's like no
people actually know what's going on and
they're frustrated with the bs so
it was a cool moment to see that to see
that people across the political divide
i mean the weird thing about this movie
is it got some great responses across
the red blue
political divide which um you know i
didn't know what to expect but when i
saw that it was uh
it was actually hopeful
cool
cool
okay so at this point we're going to
reveal some of the things that happened
at the end of the movie
so alert if you're not okay
so you can sort of fast forward to the
next segment if you'd like to
right now
so i was particularly intrigued by meryl
streep's character playing the president
of the united states and
um there there's a
is she based on some amalgam of
personalities out there that you thought
would do just right as president
no no just one
ah
sorry sorry
oh i mean there's definitely a big old
tablespoon
of the last president in there that's
sort of blinding narcissism
only responding to the moment no
foresight
no question that's in there but you know
hey i talked to merrell about it and
you know there's also a little bit of
bill clinton in there there's some you
know the used car salesman kind of slick
you know sort of nefarious bill clinton
there's also
you know half a tablespoon of george w
bush dangerously unqualified so
unfortunately well plus it was the
announcement on the battleship the
announcement on the ship was part of
that right yeah there's some scenes
there
yeah so so that's why i didn't um so
chuck i didn't
uniquely identify any
one
actor with any one real other person
there was enough of an amalgam there
that i i saw all of society all of
american society uh folded into
practically all of those characters from
the see the other problems
i'm not as smart as either one of you so
what a simple character yeah what i saw
was what i wanted to see i saw what i
wanted to see
i i was wondering adam up to that point
are
are people just a lens not a lens are
they their own filter and they will then
see in this like what chuck said what
they want to see without really grasping
the fuller storytelling that you imbued
it with
i mean i i was really happy with how
people got it i mean people
got the idea you know there's jokes in
the movies about super donors being
allowed in the white house you know
clearly the media is just concerned with
good cheer and keeping the ratings up
and
it was pretty amazing
to see those reactions and even the
ending of the movie where you know once
all the white noise of our kind of
for-profit kind of uh jumble of media
goes away how things got real and got
about family and
faith like people really
got into it i i was like really happy
with that part of the response even
though there was certainly an element
that was like didn't dig it
um for the most part though the public
at large was was dialing into it um so
you know you never know you have these
feelings you make a movie
kind of seems like how the world is now
i mean you even look at the white house
now
which is you know uh the opposition
party and then the congress is owned by
the opposition party well what's going
on with them they're stuck in the mud
because of dirty money and they're not
doing anything
so you know these problems i i think
we've been scammed in some ways with
this red blue game yes i think it's all
about dirty money big money and if we
could just get that out things would
start moving a lot better so
it was cool to see people around the
world identify with that and know that
was the case so let me ask you this did
you did you do this on purpose or was it
just a byproduct of or a natural
outworking
of what you just mentioned
it at the end
there was kind of a
admirable nod to ai
in a very humorous way
where the technology and the prediction
or the predictive analytics of
technology
came true
but at the same time the reliance upon
the people who run technology
effed everything up was that purposeful
wow
chuck win deep
chocolate deep
three layers
um
yeah i mean like you know it's
incredible these algorithms that they
use for social media wait wait wait
chuck it sound like he didn't intend any
of that at all uh yeah
yeah i did that on purpose
that's what adam that's what you sounded
like just then i'm sorry
yeah yeah i was that brilliant when i
wrote that part by the way that's a much
better answer i should have been
mysterious and just said chuck
you got to find your own meaning in it
just make what we do that would have
been a much cooler if i had a pipe i
would have taken it off
your own meaning um no but you're right
though i mean god these you guys know
these algorithms they have for search
engines and for social media
and the way they corral us and get
emotions out of us we were definitely
playing around with that but i i like
that i like that leo's character was
told what his death was going to be and
then it wasn't that right
right even though you're right the
president did have her death that was
predicted
um so as much as the algorithms try and
corral us
i guess we were trying to make a point
like you can still stop it you know
right right right right you need without
that kind of message you know then you
just you're just pissing people off
depressing people so
let me i i it's a rare moment i have two
sort of comedic
people in front of me i love that i'm
the sorta
no that was hurtful that was
oh no no
did i say sort of i didn't mean that
okay
given that i have two comedic talents in
front of me i'd like to ask
do you think comedy is the best way to
change someone's heart
wow
i'll let i have my but i'll let adam do
this one
uh we'll see what you think chuck i mean
here's the funny thing
is you know the reason we chose comedy
with this is comedy is great
in the sense that
it's kind of a truth detector like if
you wanted to go on stage and do a
stand-up routine about how billionaires
are taxed too much i dare you to get a
laugh off of that like an audience will
know that's bogus and people have tried
they had a fox news comedy show about 15
years ago they tried to do and it just
bombed
and true
and uh so i i think comedy is great and
i also think comedy
you have to have a perspective you can't
laugh
at something if you're in the middle of
being traumatized by it like it's hard
to laugh about a crazed you know uh
monkey attacking you but like if you can
look from a distance at a crazed monkey
you can laugh at it
so i think comedy does a lot of things i
think it's a truth detector i think it
also means you have to have some
perspective you have to have a little
bit of a view of the world which
i you know personally i think that's
exactly what we need right now with the
world is so overwhelming
and confusing and ridiculous and
traumatizing that for us to be able to
step back
uh just feels good right away chuck what
do you think
for i mean i agree with everything you
just said and i also think that unlike
um
you know
any other didactic message which
immediately puts people in the defensive
and immediately causes them to withdraw
in whatever
uh thought pattern that they have
already
if they disagree if they disagree
comedy disarms you because you're
laughing first as an impulse
and then
you go hey
which is always my favorite humor
when uh you know whether i'm doing it or
somebody else is my favorite thing to
happen on stage is when i tell a joke
and people laugh and then they groan
i love that
i love that
and my answer to that every time is too
late [ __ ]
i already got you it's too late
you laughed it's already funny you can't
come back and get thrown i think that's
spot on because it's like you laugh
and then you realize in laughing the
world is not black and white exactly at
all contradictions like i always say
with this movie people are like oh
you're trying to warn people about
climate and you're doing all this well
what are you doing i'm like don't get me
wrong i'm a [ __ ] i like if there's a
new ad for like a taco bell combo
burrito
filled with mini tacos i'm like i want
to eat that and like i i'm i'm way too
invested in is our affleck and jennifer
lopez happy together like i'm way too
invested in that so
it's like we're all like this i mean
we're all animals that love like great
smells and bright colors
but you know there's a little part of us
too that can do something like step back
and take a look at stuff so that combo
is kind of the whole game which i think
is what chuck's talking about it is and
by the way adam let me just say this i'm
stealing your idea of the taco stuffed
burrito
which i'm going to try and sell to taco
bell and call it the pregnant burrito oh
by the way wouldn't you order that in a
heartbeat without a doubt a taco stuffed
burrito oh my god you know burrito that
has mini tacos inside of it yes there's
like 20 little tacos inside a burrito
it's a burrito made of tacos neil i mean
i get that you're assigning no that's
too meta for me that's too meta you know
profession the scientific community
never could have thought of what chuck
and i are around here yeah the
burrito turducken come
i love on i love it
so what uh what do you know about the
movie's been out for several months now
don't look up on netflix what what do
you know about what impact has it has
had
you know uh some of it's anecdotal in
some cases netflix gives you all these
crazy statistics but i mean it's been
really cool i've just seen some you know
stories where
uh an opposition leader in the french
government the other day referred to
macron's inaction over the climate as
he's like janie orlean from don't look
up i saw the organization of cop in uh
in glasgow refer to don't look up i've
seen
it's been mentioned in articles about
leaders that are denying science
extinction rebellion in the uk has
rallied around the film and has been
mentioning it
um so that's really cool and then they
show you the stats where it's like
you know by some estimates 250 to 300
million
people have seen the movie and
and then they show you the social media
responses and they're
showing you that it's four to one
positive and
uh so you know there's a lot of stats
there's a lot of anecdotal but
i can just say but i like the fact that
if if if reference to the movie and its
characters becomes part of pop culture
then right
i don't know what more you could ever
hope a movie to do
right right there are movies that are in
our common parlance that we you know say
oh it's let's go to oz right we know
what that means it's part of our
it's part of our lexicon our cinematic
literacy
so
that's i think that's an excellent
measure and there's perhaps no better
measure
of the influence of a movie than people
absorbing it
the idea that there's now a phrase for
self-interested leaders and media
and conglomerates ignoring science
and it's don't look up is like and it
seems to kind of be catching i mean it's
still a little early but
if that was the result i we're we're
doing backflips i mean we just tried
to get something out there to kind of
jar some people and it's just a movie
so you know your hopes are are fairly
modest but uh it succeeded although of
course the tagline of this show the
tagline of the show is the opposite of
that right i end every show with
keep looking up yeah and so
to to
to watch the movie to hear everything
don't look up it's like each one of
those was like a dagger to my yeah
you know what adam you should have named
your show f you neil tyson
that's what that that's i felt that
every time someone said don't look up we
were
i know adam you didn't leave the viewer
any hope at the end
except for the the the infinitely rich
who went on the
the ship
and we didn't like any of them anyway so
so
so
what does it mean to offer no hope this
is america we like some hope ah well you
know i mean here's the thing it's just a
movie it's a rather we like
yeah it's it's a fictional outcome but
we definitely
were very conscious of the fact that we
have seen thousands of movies for
decades that have the guaranteed happy
ending right and you know we were trying
to say if you you know we're not
audience members we're part of this and
unless you do something
there's not a guaranteed happy ending so
it was amazing to see how much that
ending really
hit people just because it broke the
kind of routine that we're used to but
make no mistake about it uh
science is powerful science is the
excalibur on the wall if we take it down
and use it
uh we can deal with this this urgent
urgent climate crisis i mean we have
renewable energy it's always what you
could have had no adam what you could
have had was a small faction of people
in your movie
who watched star talk
okay
i apologize
they band together and then they figure
out how to convince everybody how to
properly deflect the asteroid and earth
is saved see you could you could have
had that that could have been the ending
maybe we'll release that version but um
the director's cut
could have a bunch of people laughing at
chuck's stand up and then through the
joy of their laughter
they see the world clearly and they get
the governments to do it could have been
either one of those or we could have had
the reality of that same scenario where
they're actually egging on the end of
the world because they're watching
[Laughter]
um
well but like
yeah but rather rather than sit through
chuck's routine right i'd rather the
world end is that what you're saying
even so come asteroid now
there are some uh so adam you probably
got this in your stream it when i posted
my twitter comment about the film uh the
response was wide and varied and many
were humorous one of the one of them
said by the end of the film i was
rooting for the comet
they didn't care about anybody yeah yeah
so adam let me get at least a little
half serious here if a movie has the
power to move people
intellectually
emotionally
you what you have done with don't look
up
is hold up a mirror to us all
but
a movie also has the power to offer a
solution
and you didn't offer a solution
a solution to get to cut through
the brush and bramble and the muck and
mire of social media and and
and political idiocy so you could have
and you didn't
so
is that
what do you want people to do
yeah i mean i think this movie was a
kick in the pants i mean this movie was
you know what we're missing when it
comes to the climate crisis is will in
action right those two things and that a
lot of people don't feel the urgency in
their bones and i'm not saying
they're at fault it just is what it is
so this movie was designed to be a big
old
kick in the pants and what i hope is i
hope other people and certainly our
production companies doing it i want to
see other movies other tv shows i want
to see
you know the news start to cover the
media start to cover the different ways
we can deal with this because there are
a lot of ways we can i mean we have the
renewable energy
there's there's some early research
going on with carbon removal that's
really exciting carbon sequestration
yeah yeah or but the fossil fuel
companies will come in and use those
solutions as a way to slow us down so
you got to kind of distinguish between
the good faith and bad faith solutions
but uh but yeah it is ultimately one
movie
and uh we could only tell so much of a
story and the goal of it was a kick in
the pants a moment of identification for
people that have felt gaslit
and a chance for people to have a little
perspective on how
you know uh uh
i was gonna say am i allowed to curse no
who cares oh i was gonna say bat [ __ ]
crazy our world is
i was gonna say guano crazy our world is
and wow i like that
[Laughter]
yeah guano is worth more money anyway on
the open market
that was the goal of the movie and yeah
you're you're 100 right neil like well
let me just let me just dovetail on that
for you know being serious which i think
he just gave us a beautiful ending to
the segment yeah
okay i have to do this neil and that is
when you talk about
the solution so yale and george mason
have a study and in that study one of
the things that was most prominent is
the fact that one of the biggest
problems with climate is that people do
not talk about it so when you talk about
the impact of movies having a shockwave
the fallout is if people talk about it
that is part of the solution
i uh you just gave my answer in your
question yeah that's it is like i don't
think people realize how much power they
have in just
the people they talk to the way they
behave
feeling an emotion i mean you know
advertising companies are trying to
replicate word of mouth that's what
they're trying to replicate but every
study shows like nothing's more powerful
than people just talking to each other
so that was it that was the goal of this
one let's get a little spark going and
uh i'm gonna summarize what both of you
just said by quoting ray bradbury
and so ray bradbury will take us out of
this segment he said
when asked by a fan
because ray bradbury the science fiction
writer said why do you always portray
these apocalyptic futures for humanity
is that the future you think we're going
to have
and he says no
i show you those futures so you know to
avoid them oh
very nice good that is good stuff it's
good
you know it's not a competition neil
i'll do the
i'll do the plug guys and as always this
segment is brought to you by exxon exxon
filling all your oil and gas needs
excellent care for you and your family
exxon don't look up
and adam great to have you keep being
crazy out there and doing things that
no one else would even think of doing
and thereby changing the world
for the better when we come back we're
going to invite in my friend and
colleague amy mainser who's an
astrophysicist who's one of the world's
experts on planetary protection
protecting earth from asteroids and
she's going to talk about a recent
mission launched by nasa to test whether
we have the power to deflect asteroids
when star talk returns
we're back star talk we're talking about
cosmic things that can harm humans on
earth coming off a great interview with
adam mckay writer producer director of
don't look up the netflix hit movie and
now we bring in a friend and colleague
amy mainser amy welcome back to star
talk hey thanks it's great to be back
the last i checked in on you you were at
the jet propulsion labs in
pasadena california and where are you
now
well i have since moved and now i'm at
the university of arizona in the
department of planetary science very
cool
at one of the jewels in the crown of
that institution uh all the all that
whenever they look up
they find something good
at the university of arizona so that's
one of the uh one of the finest
departments around so thank great to
have you back on star talk now why do we
have you here we could have had you
anyway just because your expertise
thinking about stuff that can harm us
but
you double down on that as being like
the science astro advisor to the film
don't look up
and so we're going to do is we solicited
questions from our audience and a
zillion of them came in but just before
we go to those check you got chuck
you're loaded up with those questions i
am yeah yeah okay well good to go we're
good to go so before we do that let me
just ask you amy what
did they want you to do for the film
well you know i think the role of
science advisor probably is different
for every movie or tv show but for this
one uh there was quite a bit to do there
was a basically advising adam and the
rest of the cast and the crew on the
actual asteroid and comet science but
kind of even more basically there was a
kind of a task of advising them on what
it means to be a scientist and how do
scientists think
and what do we do when we have
bad news to tell everybody based on what
we're learning
so it's interesting i implicated you
i think probably correctly because they
wouldn't have known this otherwise on
the on the in the scripting uh i was
interviewed by msnbc and they played a
scene about don't look up and they
played a scene
where i forgot which character asserts
it it might have been leonardo dicaprio
he says a comet the size of mount
everest is going to hit earth and i say
well you don't get that size just by
accident because that was the size of
the comet that took out the dinosaurs
and so
a real astronomer had to be in there
sort of infusing these these reference
frames for them so
did i correctly credit you for telling
them that oh yeah thank you yes
you did
you check my people my people
our people we all know how we got to
talk see exactly just so you know yes
the dinosaurs died and so are you or so
will you
that's all will you yes right yeah well
hopefully not hopefully not this time
did you also coach them on the behavior
of scientists as scientists rather than
just script points yeah we really talked
about a lot of different aspects of what
it means to be a scientist just you know
how do scientists think what are the
things that sort of frustrate us and how
do we you know how do we succeed and
sometimes how do we fail when we try to
communicate with the public and and with
people who are we're in power to make
decisions about what's going to happen
to all of us yeah but okay but wait a
minute though you are very good at
communicating with the public how do you
train actors to be bad at communicating
with the public
well i think if you told them all you
knew they would have been much much
better at it so how do you tell them
what you don't know and have them be bad
at it well it's funny because we we
leonardo and i especially talk a lot
about this this part that you know
there's a tendency in science to to use
a lot of jobs i can say that i i mean
first name basis first of all don't
even try to just
bury that lead
[Laughter]
don't even try let the woman be first
name basis with all these people dude
wait a minute no uh you know she didn't
call him leo
leonardo and i we talk a lot about it's
like and we know that you're not doing a
seance with da vinci like okay
but go ahead i'm pretty cool which would
have been very cool that would have been
even cooler
very cool even yeah cool we talked a lot
about just you know what is it what is
it that's so confusing sometimes
obviously we use a ton of jargon and we
do it sometimes without even meaning to
i mean you guys encounter this all the
time right i mean we use words in a
scientific context same word use it in
everyday life and it takes on a totally
different meaning sometimes
the word uncertainty for example in
science that has a very specific
definition we use it in almost a
mathematical context but if you say in
everyday life well i'm uncertain as to
whether there is a rattlesnake in my
backyard you know that means you don't
know right but to a scientist that that
that word is used in a very different
way so we talked about so people don't
know that we can quantify our ignorance
and that's a actually profound place to
be yeah
i was going to say that certainties
that's very scientist of you
we can quantify our ignorance
yeah well science deals in probabilities
all the time right i mean that's just
part of what we do as scientists is we
are trying to quantify how likely it is
something's going to happen
but that we're not happening yeah we're
not happy yeah
and that's a that's a sometimes a kind
of a hard thing to get across but i
think also too just generally you know
more basically can we agree that there
are facts that are supported by
scientific data that are true and that's
a big theme of the movie can we have
something that we all agree on that is
true
so you weren't just a random
astrophysicist to advise them you
actually have expertise
in asteroid
risks
so
what can you tell us give us just some
numbers how many asteroids have us in
their path just so we can freak
everybody out before we start the q a
well the very good news is okay full
stop the movie is pure science fiction
okay we don't know no it's not so you're
lying that was a documentary i told
everybody that okay
we were very lucky there is no comet
that we know about that is about to
smack into the earth in six months full
stop we don't know of any such objects
seven months yes but six months let's
say that yeah okay yeah let's point
there and let's go straight to questions
check it out i don't know what you're
doing in six months and two days but
wouldn't it
wouldn't make any plans
live it up for now yep leave it up for
now
give me some questions
alex reynoso who kind of dovetails on dr
tyson's questions says hello alex from
mexico here my question for dr mainzer
is were you asked for any new ideas for
the movie or did they just ask you to
fact check the ideas they already had
and i love that question if so what was
the craziest idea that you fact checked
uh well i would say yeah we we had a lot
of back and forth about the script and
it was it was you know we started
working on it more than two years ago
now so it's been a while
first off uh i had to work with adam to
figure out the size of the comet
actually well first of all we had to
establish that it was a comet and not an
asteroid so that was number one number
two uh he wanted it to be a lot bigger
than i thought was was a good idea for
the script so i had him kind of downsize
it a little bit and i told him at a
certain point if the thing is too big
you know there is no movie right there's
no hope at all so we wanted to try to
size it to something that is is uh you
know is large enough that it would have
caused a lot of damage in the movie
obviously that's part of the plot but
but not so large that everybody would
just give up and stop trying right off
the bat so so that was number one so
that getting the size of the comet right
was uh was kind of one of the first
orders of business
interesting that's right all right but
how about weird but was there something
you added other than the size of the
comment that they already knew was going
to hit was there some extra plot line
you said you know you got to add this to
the storytelling otherwise it's not real
yeah so there's a there's kind of a key
i'm assuming this is spoilers are okay
here i'm hoping everybody's seen the
movie at this point but um yeah one of
the things that we talk a lot about that
is uh is is features pretty heavily in
the plot is uh the concept that
somebody's going to want to come along
and instead of just deflecting the comet
they're going to want to try to mine the
cost yes i i was very impressed with
that
with that turn of the of the plot line
yeah yeah so basically there's sort of a
key moment when it looks like everybody
in spite of all their differences has
kind of gotten all their stuff together
and we're going to deflect the comment
and everything is going according to
plan
and then all of a sudden there's a
wrench in the works a plot twist very
good yeah
and we're reminded that indeed comets
and asteroids are very rich in minerals
and natural resources so that that
factual dimension of it made it
comedically authentic for someone to say
let's exploit this for economic gain
yeah jeff bezos comes in and says hey
i i we got we got i got a trillion
dollars up there of coming at us okay
and you want to blow it up
what are you doing yeah
we could ship that overnight
oh gosh
yeah no we gotta we gotta i mean this
was this was something we talked a lot
about in the movie because you know
there's been a lot of talk about
asteroid mining we do have asteroids
sample return missions
in fact there's two of them one has
already brought a sample back from an
asteroid that's hayabusa ii and there's
another that's on its way back to earth
right now and that's osiris-rex but both
of these missions are bringing back kind
of the equivalent of about a baseball
size worth of material maybe a coffee
can's worth but that's it
we're not talking tons and tons and tons
of minerals here we're talking a
baseball so
okay so this sample return amy so
we'll get to this a little later maybe
in the next segment but uh that means
you're bringing space
stuff back to earth that can't always be
good
even if it did have economic value
thinking of like space viruses or
something nice we'll get to that just
want to tease what could happen later
all right chuck give me another one all
right
let's see if we can mine these questions
you see what i did there yeah well this
one's about space herpes so
no
you said space virus so anyway here we
go uh
hello dr mainzer dr tyson and lord nice
oh please uh since darts encount uh
since dart's counterpart aim was
cancelled and thus
we're relying on ground-based telescopes
to observe the effects of dart
will the mission still provide us with
enough data to determine if a kinetic
impactor
could counter the scenario like the one
depicted and don't look up
or
will further tests be necessary uh by
the way i appreciate your work on neo
wise greetings from germany the place
where we like to show off how much we
know
about everything
okay patrick
you know you could have just asked a
question patrick you didn't have to give
us a dissertation on how you yourself
are an astrophysicist and let me ask amy
all about it
come on man okay
okay so dark amy quick what's dark
so dart is the double asteroid
redirection test first of all and it is
a mission that is going to a double
asteroid so it's an asteroid that's got
a moon going around it and the idea is
to to bump into the moon so the idea is
to take the spacecraft and just crash it
into the moon and bump the moon a little
bit so that you can see the moon's orbit
change
so the idea is to test this so-called
kinetic impactor technique in other
words the energy of motion can we change
the orbit of this of this asteroids moon
in a way that is detectable so what is
aim then what happened to aim so the
there was a proposal to have another
mission that would that would watch the
impact in real time so basically just
watch the impactor happen uh or watch
the impact happen and see whether or not
there was a big explosion off the
asteroid or or what have you now there's
a couple of things so the aim mission
didn't end up happening as proposed and
was that an acronym and was that an
acronym oh yes and it ah i'm gonna have
to look it up asteroid
[Music]
imaging let me make this up right now
let's just do it now yeah asteroid uh
asteroid imaging mission
okay yeah maneuver maneuver yeah okay
good question i don't actually remember
the name
murder i was gonna go with murder
okay so so aim did not make it however
however they are going to watch it with
the ground-based telescopes as the as
the questioner noted and
and there is a cubesat that's been
provided by the italian space agency
that is going to be watching the impact
as well so there's that the other thing
is the europeans have a mission that is
going to go there eventually uh in a
couple years after the impact and it
will come back to the asteroids moon and
it's going to do a very careful mapping
of the system so hopefully between all
of that we can we can piece it all
together what are these videos i've seen
where it's some part of of of dart
detaches while the rest of it collides
yeah i think this is the uh the the
cubesat with the observer the camera
okay because they were together and then
they separated and one went in for the
for the collision yeah so i believe it's
got a it's got a little friend that's
going to that is going to drop off and
take a look at things we got to take a
quick break when we come back more
cosmic queries with
a collision end of earth end of all
civilization expert
amy mainzer
advisor to the netflix hit film don't
look up when we return
we're back with amy mainser amy a friend
and colleague uh planetary scientist uh
amy how do we find you on social media
what where do you hang out
uh i'm on twitter so i'm at amy meinzer
on twitter that's right my job
mispronouncing your last name shame on
me it's either way okay
m-a-i-n-z-e-r
all right you're feeling particularly
german you could say mine sir
yes okay
don't get chuck started on his actions
do you have some papers
your peer-reviewed papers
i did say the english for the american
pronunciation one time in front of my
german grandfather and boy did i get an
earful oh
we want some more of that chuckle fill
in for him
say chuck you're bringing back memories
all right let's get another question
chuck see i mean we can squeeze into
this final segment uh this is dylan he
says greeting doctors and comedians from
albuquerque new mexico i was wondering
what size do asteroids
become dangerous not just mount everest
size i know that earth pounds through
millions of particles from space that
they do nothing
in other words we get bombarded all the
time um what can we expect
when an asteroid that could potentially
kill all life what's the smallest that
it could be
well so we do have some good information
about this and the question's absolutely
correct or the question is absolutely
correct we do get pelted with all kinds
of little particles all the time every
day about 100 tons and we mostly see
those if we see them at all as shooting
stars because they're tiny these things
are like sand grains or maybe the size
of a grain of rice or a p something like
that but we know that if an object gets
to be bigger say about maybe 20 meters
across so about 60 50 60 feet across at
that point it can start to make it
through the earth's atmosphere
more or less intact now we know this is
a reasonable lower limit because we have
a really recent event well recent on
astronomer time scales um in 2013 there
was an object that uh that hit over
russia and it exploded remember that it
exploded in the upper atmosphere and
there was a shower fragments it broke a
bunch of windows but there wasn't a big
hole in the ground right it was it was
mostly just an air burst explosion and
that's because the object was small
enough that the atmosphere was
effectively like a brick wall and really
just shredded it but
if the object's closer to safe 50 meters
across
then what happens is you get what we
have here in arizona which is a mile
wide hole in the ground more or less so
very small differences in the size
relatively speaking can make a really
big difference okay for those who've
never been arizona she referenced a
a practically mild diameter meteor
crater sitting there uh near winslow
arizona isn't that right isn't it that's
right one of the closest towns a town
has showed up in a song something i've
been talking to with in winslow arizona
what's that song
it's uh
by the eagles
mile mile wide crater
really large crater yeah
okay so the takeaway from that answer
amy is that occasionally um rice and
peas falls from the sky
you said that
we heard you say that space materials
it's like it's like earth sweating it's
like earth's sweating rice and peas rice
and peas i heard her say that she's on
the record right that's it the comments
are helping us celebrate every day
that's it that's it
hey so i i it just occurred to me
because you said about the shock wave in
2013. so that was not a very big uh
object that uh impacted the atmosphere
to create this shock wave so
would something decide what would it
take to actually just blow the
atmosphere off because the first thing
that it would hit
would be it would make the air like an
ocean our atmosphere would be like an
ocean right because it hits it whereby
chuck are you asking this question or is
this a patreon question that you're
supposed to be reading from which oh
wait that's wait that's from
that's from
that's from buck rice
buck rice
buck rice from rice and peas arizona
would like to know
all right let me tighten up chuck's
question for you amy yeah so at what
size asteroid is unfazed by moving
through the atmosphere and then it just
hits the ground as though there was no
atmosphere at all that's what you were
trying to that's what i was trying to
say but i i don't know what i'm talking
about no no it is this is exactly the
question if it's a little bit bigger
than 20 meters
it's going to make it to the ground
mostly intact and by the time you get to
about 50 meters across
now it can blow a pretty big hole in the
ground
so
now the thing that hit into your crater
there's a caveat it's made of mostly
nickel iron because we found some pieces
of it that didn't get completely
vaporized but chuck she meant nickel
plus iron when she said nickel iron just
so you know there's not some new element
that that only she knows about
together in the universe supernova make
them and so they're everywhere together
so it's not a surprise we find them
together in chunks of things in the
solar system so amy if i remember
correctly the one that hit over russia
was a rocky a stoney meteorite
and
but that's not what fell in arizona
that's correct yeah the one that hit
over russia was uh was a kind of a
common type of stony asteroid so sort of
average in its properties but the one
that the the impacted in arizona about
50 000 years ago that was made of mostly
nickel and iron so a much higher density
material it wasn't a whole lot bigger it
was about 50 meters across instead of 20
meters across but probably a pretty high
density compared to the stony object
that exploded over russia
wow
and and that creator by the way can sink
a 62-story building
i've been there several times it's it's
great if you go to arizona put that on
your list if you're if you're a fan of
this podcast and you go to arizona wave
to amy as you go by tucson but then go
to go to this crater
and check it out i definitely recommend
it it is impressive
and i think there's a subway uh merch uh
a concession stand up at the top you can
eat a sandwich while you're there i
thought you were going to say the subway
stocks
i was like when did the mta
get that
[Laughter]
i thought coney island was fun
next up meteor crater all right chuck go
for it all right here we go this is uh
whoo
i'm gonna say aya
buena cosa
okay whatever um aya buena cosa says hi
i am from the philippines here uh what
would be the place where humans could
possibly survive earth's destruction
would you still want to live after that
is there any place you can hide from
a extinction level impact
well let's put it this way it is thought
we we know a lot about what happens
because we can look back at the at the
event that wiped out the dinosaurs right
and in fact uh neil's home institution
there at amnh does a lot of research on
this american museum of natural history
yeah american museum of natural history
has done a lot of work on this but
basically we know from studying the
fossil records that pretty much any form
of life that was bigger than about 50
pounds went extinct
and that's because the food webs really
collapsed there wasn't a lot to eat for
a very long time
life did eventually come back and
rediversify after that impact event but
it took millions of years for that to
happen so it was not a fast process on
our time scales so i would say that you
know
it's it's bad we definitely don't want
this to happen and we can learn about
present-day climate change that we're
causing as human beings by looking back
at that event and seeing exactly how
things unfolded in fact i would say the
obvious conclusion from that event is
that doing large uncontrolled
experiments on our atmosphere is a
really bad idea and we shouldn't be
doing it
well plus plus amy i think that there's
a there's an important point that you're
making there which is many people think
that when the asteroid hits
that's what kills you an
extinction-level asteroid no it's
because it takes out the food chain
right it takes out the base of the food
chain and everything that eats that goes
extinct and everything that eats the
animals that ate the food go extinct and
so it's this wave of extinction
percolating across the tree of life that
can take about how long how long did it
take all those animals to die do we know
well we know from the fossil record that
it uh it was pretty fast but on
geological time scale so in other words
that could have been you know thousands
of years thousands of years so we lose
we lose most of the species over
thousands of years not because they they
were hit by the asteroid itself which is
how you get a small asteroid small the
size of mount everest affecting life
everywhere on on earth and you made such
an important point amy that
the only way that can kill life around
the other side of the earth is if it
affected the climate
and and then we learn what we're doing
are we
amy are we
an everest scale
collision
well let's put it this way we should do
everything in our power to make sure
that we're not the asteroid
or the comet our conduct is not yeah
well we at least we got the first part
of it right
ass
um
ass as an asteroid okay yes exactly okay
don't be an ass director
next question chuck
hello everyone my name is pronounced
bridge really okay
all right
would it be possible to eventually put a
detection system at points in space like
the moon or mars
and uh would it wouldn't even be
necessary wait detection or deflection
um oh good good thing no he says
detection but i like your question too
detection anti-flexible yeah let's do it
all right yeah so i mean you know of
course we've got ground-based telescopes
we even have a space-based telescope
right now we have neo-wise the
near-earth object rifled in front survey
explorer neowise is the project i work
on and we're building a new one that's
going to go in space that will
eventually replace uh neowise because
neolize is now very old
that's called the near-earth object
surveyor and it's not going to go on the
moon but it's going to go just past the
orbit of the moon so not too much
further away in principle if we have
these telescopes plus we've got the
reuben observatory that's going to be
coming online in chile uh pretty soon
hopefully and so with all of those
expanded capabilities we should be in
pretty good shape we should be able to
map out where most of the really big
stuff is at that point now could we look
at other options absolutely and one of
the things we'll do is we start to get
data from the more advanced surveys is
we'll look at the population models and
figure out okay what do we do about the
rest of the objects what's the best way
to search for them we could try building
astro or building observatories on the
moon and on mars but it's it's hard to
do that of course
um so amy i have to stop you everything
after i stop everything you just said is
just so that we know when to kiss our
ass goodbye
you haven't said anything about
deflection you just you just talk about
oh now we have a catalog of all the
things that will kill us and the date
and time so i need more than that from
you amy yes well well okay i am hoping
full stop i am hoping that when we make
our big catalog we find nothing and
that's a great that would be the best
possible answer good point okay right we
could look out there and we could see
that you know what they've nothing for
ten thousand years yeah just fine we're
good we're fine it's we're all fine here
you know and equipment star wars a
little bit um but you know we could find
that and that would be the best case of
course we don't want to we don't want to
just assume the best case though we do
want to make plans for deflection and
that's that's where the dart mission
comes in that was a test of that kinetic
impactor technology which is kind of the
easiest thing you can imagine where you
just bump into the the asteroid with the
spacecraft there are other technologies
though that we could look at like uh
something called
willis yes yes the bruce willis
technology um which i'm always in favor
of but but
you can always send bruce willis that's
probably going to help but if you want
to do something else you can look at
something called the gravity tractor and
i'm not talking about a john deere
tractor i'm talking about a mass in
space so in other words you build a
really big spacecraft something very big
and heavy and you park it next to the
asteroid and then you just sort of let
the gravity of the spacecraft pull on
the asteroid and try to tow it out of
the way
of course that only works if you have a
pretty long time oh yeah yeah yeah so
that's a gravitational tractor beam i
love the concept of that yeah
yeah
chuck i think we might have time for
only one more question this is sad
because we're talking about this the
future of life on earth and and we got
to fit it into our time slots that that
that's the wrong that's just wrong well
yeah yeah i mean honestly it makes sense
too you know uh because
we're sad
and the way we're responding to
everything is sad yes yes
all right here we go i'm sorry i
shouldn't be a downer on humankind i'm
sure we'll get it together okay here we
go uh this is daniel kolakowski
and daniel says first
dr tyson were you consulted on the movie
title
no
that's pretty funny
that's good that's good the answer is no
but as i watched the movie i kept i felt
each of those don't look ups as like a
dagger into my heart because every day i
tell people to look up and they're
saying don't look up and a movie is way
more powerful than i am in messaging the
public so i it was like tiny that you
know the death of a thousand cuts that's
how i felt nice yeah so then he says uh
second uh chuck just take a deep breath
and then pronounce my name exactly as it
looks you'll get it right okay well
thank you for your very thank you for
your very zen
your very zen instructions i hope i hope
i should have read that first
because now i don't know
all right
and then third uh dr meinzer in the
opening scene where leo is calculating
the trajectory of the asteroid how is he
able to do that accurately in discrete
steps rather than using a method to
calculate the trajectory with calculus
or a computer model
could he really be that smart
well what happens in the movie is we're
kind of condensing a few things down but
the upshot is is that leo is not an
expert in comet discovery uh so he's
going back to grad school and he's got a
bunch of students with them so i kind of
thought you know if i were a professor
in that situation
i probably would want to try to actually
work out the math if i could to show the
students how it's done so in other words
use it as a teachable moment so in the
movie he's kind of using it as a
teachable moment he's looking at a
textbook he's trying to figure out the
math for himself rather than just going
right to the computer he's actually
trying to kind of work it out if you
look carefully you will see that they
are using their laptops and he is
actually writing stuff down on the board
that they're that they're getting off of
the computer so they are actually using
the computer but there's kind of a scene
in the beginning where he's he's going
to try and figure it out for himself a
little bit just to make sure he
understands it and i think that's what a
good scientist will try to do but i
think the question was he's showing
discrete steps of the location of the
comet and then one step the separation
between earth and the comet is zero
wouldn't that happen as a continuous
calculation or or a a mathematical
function that gets you there like the
guy said whose name is we didn't
pronounce uh would you use calculus
which then gets you the continuous
solution oh absolutely yeah so you do
use calculus although the method that
he's using is referred to as gauss's
method and this is a sort of a classical
method of orbit determination the idea
is you actually iterate so in other
words you make an initial guess and then
you kind of refine the guess based on an
estimate of how far off you are and then
you do it again and again and again and
after that then you can start looking at
discrete steps in time once you have a
pretty good idea of what the orbit is
the next step is to figure out where's
the object going at these specific
points in time and so that's kind of
what's showing there's sort of a
two-step process there now gauss is my
man gauss is my man
gauss is the google maps of orbit
plotting
did you know gauss invented the method
of least squares in statistics
to solve the
orbit of the first asteroid ever
discovered so this is deep
the asteroid series was in space moving
and then it got lost in the sun's glare
we don't gonna look guys i got this okay
so he used the previous measures
extrapolated into the future into the
future using the single best method
possible and to do that he invented the
method of least squares on asteroids i'm
just saying
we got people everywhere working working
on stuff well
what a slouch he was
god if only if only that gauss had tried
hard
what he could have made of himself
[Laughter]
so uh let's try to slip in one more
question chuck see what you got okay and
amy you got to answer quick on this
pretend you're in pretend on the evening
news and you got to give me a sound bite
okay go you got it you got it all right
here we go guys uh this would be an easy
one because we almost got to it but
michaela negus says uh
what valuable resources exist in
asteroids and how much money could be
made by mining them
right directly related to the movie
now i have said i have said amy that the
world's first trillionaire will be the
person who exploits the natural
resources on asteroids so how am i right
or am i wrong
tell me here boy i tell you what it's a
it's a science fiction question in a lot
of ways because it's really hard to do
stuff in space we can bring back kind of
baseball size or copy can size bunches
of material bringing back a lot more
than that so far has been really
challenging for us maybe we will get
there someday but right now we're still
talking baseball size amounts of
material so we're we're still in the uh
i don't know maybe we'll get there
someday but we need we need some star
trek to happen first
yeah but in 1902 before the airplane was
invented if you said in 67 years gonna
be walking on the moon they would have
put you they would have committed you so
so how far off are you are you thinking
i mean that can't be more far off than
walking on the moon before the wright
brothers flew yeah it's it's hard to say
you know i mean gosh so many people have
tried to predict the future and have
been way way wrong so i mean you know
who knows but i will i want you on
record so we can embarrass you in 10
years okay there we go there we go i
think it it's probably the case that in
10 years we're not going to be towing
back whole big chunks of asteroid
probably about 10 years is too soon but
you know after that who knows
it's very appealing to try to do it
because we all know that you know
there's a lot of limited resources on
earth so we would love to get that that
yucky mining stuff off the planet if we
can what your sentence was there's a lot
of limited resources is that what you
just said well i say there's oh gosh
is that your sentence was that actually
yourself
can we edit that part out
i'd have to oh gosh yeah no i mean
there's there's limited resources on
earth right of all these rare materials
right and we do use them to make things
like cell phones and computer screens
and all this stuff so we definitely want
to find more sources of them but it's
just really hard to do stuff in space
right now and it's hard to bring
material back hopefully someday we can
figure all this stuff out so that we can
tow asteroids back in ways that are safe
and then chop them up and extract the
minerals without having to do it on the
ground especially asteroids that might
have taken us out then we say so there
we're going to eat you
it revenge on those asteroids yes all
right uh last one word question amy
are we all gonna die
not from an asteroid oh
oh no all right you heard it here there
you go america it's still heart disease
so heart disease so eat your broccoli
no we will die if we behave the way they
did in the movie you advised so that
they made that clear we got to end it
there amy a delight to have you back on
star talk um we're going to do this
again maybe we'll talk about uh uh
infestations from space and planetary
protection because i know you've got
some thinking on that as well chuck
always good to have you man always a
pleasure all right this has been
star talk cosmic queries everything that
might kill us from space
neil degrasse tyson here your personal
astrophysicist
keep looking up
don't look up
[Laughter]
[Music]
you